hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about in a way it's two subjects
but it's one subject the issue of
learning to speak a language like a
native okay when I say it's two subjects
because there are two issues there one
is the issue of how we use the language
our use of words our ability to use you
know the structures accurately correctly
the sort of language usage side of the
equation and then there's the
pronunciation or the accent and now in
both of those our goal of course is to
speak like a native we would like to use
words like a native we would like to use
the grammatical structures at the native
uses we would like to have an accent
that is indistinguishable from the
native now in my view oh and one other
thing that's kind of connected with that
is the issue of fluency and what it
means to be fluent and so really the
reason I am doing this video is because
I have an exchange with one of my
viewers here and we were talking about
what it means to be fluent and this
person said that you know fluency I make
the point that fluency is essentially
being able to do whatever you need to do
in most situations
you're comfortable you're not hesitating
and therefore you need a lot of words
you can't be fluent if all you can do is
ask for the bathroom and chitchat now
this person said no he feels that he or
she feels that if he can chat with the
waiter or waitress in a restaurant or
have you know some degree of
conversation and adds I consider fluency
the ability to do what you set out to do
in the language if you learn it to meet
people and learn about them and you
don't stutter I say it's fluent for what
it is and he asked with a minimal accent
if any okay so
suggestion here is that if you have a
minimal accent if any and you can make
some limited kind of polite conversation
and if that is your goal and if you're
able to do that then you have achieved
fluency based on your goal in my view
the issue of an accent is irrelevant I
know lots of people who I consider to be
fluent in English and who have in some
cases quite percent pronounced foreign
accents and it doesn't matter I have met
some people who have very little accent
very you know who are able to imitate
the the accent quite well but who don't
use the words property they sound much
worse to my ears because with limited
accent you expect the person to be able
to use the language correctly and if
they can't it almost comes off worse now
at any rate as language learners my goal
is to get as close as possible to the
native speaker I want to imitate the
native speaker we are imitating a part
of that person's culture the language we
want to get as close as possible that's
why when I listen in my language
learning and I listen a lot I only
listen to native speakers I won't listen
to non-native speakers until I'm fairly
advanced I find it less motivating to
listen to non-native speakers and I'm
trying to imitate the pronunciation I
can listen to a variety of accents you
know European Portuguese Brazilian
Portuguese or you know Mexican Spanish
Iberian Spanish and eventually I
focusing on one that I want to imitate
but in any case I want to be listening
to a native speaker so our goal is to
get close to the native speaker
we are extremely unlikely to get there I
have rarely met a person who is totally
native like there are some some of our
you know polyglot colleagues like Luka
that are very very good very close
although in English he doesn't sound
like a native speaker but he sounds very
very very close to a native speaker I
think that in French I get close to a
native speaker but I don't sound like a
native speaker speaker people can tell
that I'm not a native speaker so I think
it's nice to try to get as close as
possible to being a native speaker but
one should be realistic no on the other
hand when it comes to fluency if I look
at my own languages you know I feel I'm
fluent in certainly quite fluent in my
top five most fluent French followed by
Japanese followed by Mandarin then you
know Spanish Swedish German and even in
a language like Portuguese which I
haven't spoken a lot and therefore I
don't really speak well I am never
embarrassed I'm never in a situation
where I can't say what I want to say we
can be talking politics they can be
talking whatever that's even true in
Russian where again it's at you know
it's at the bottom getting at the bottom
of the ten languages where I would
consider myself somewhat fluent because
I haven't spoken it very much so I have
a lot of vocabulary I can become fluent
fairly quickly in fact probably I would
give myself the benefit of the doubt but
I make lots of mistakes as you saw when
I did that video so being fluent doesn't
mean that you don't make mistakes being
fluent means that you are comfortable
when you are interacting with native
speakers where you don't know you don't
control the conversation you don't know
what they're gonna talk about and you
can participate and they aren't
uncomfortable dealing with you you can
follow wherever the conversation goes
more or less so that to me is fluency
not I set myself the goal of being able
to go to the cafe chat with the waiter
and find the bathroom and
I can do that quite well and therefore
I'm fluent I don't agree with that some
people maybe that's their definition but
I think to me fluency is B - okay on a
European scale it's B - if you're there
you're fluent there's still a long way
from b2 to being to speaking like a
native
so a native at C 2 in terms of
vocabulary use of words grammatical
accuracy there are very few mistakes
when I speak French I can make mistakes
I might make some mistakes on gender or
word usage but I don't make very many of
them
so I'm actually quite close to a native
speaker in terms of use of words but I
am NOT
I don't speak like a native people can
tell that I'm not a native
maybe I should end by speaking a little
bit of French which is the language
where I get closest to being native bomb
that noise vici ad hominem Josephus I
should Japan's push problem your
response a condemned Tokyo too long
cause may trees may Sandra pas de calais
an accent sound blah blah like so you
look at look at native reenacts re-enact
so the file is on same one with modest
isabel de Bercy do Swiss Miss miss salt
- salt corrosion is people that teaches
people locator not if a normal one exam
you see Ron ploy demo de Foix but I hear
the problem the shows like he in some
part of a calm suspect we may look at
native but may family long to drop out
Scylla one could repeal of you that
circa commerce kihl-jae week it was an
offensive images do not it is offensive
beaucoup polyphagia
liebe Kulu ripple Antonio it's a deal
a process a probably probably more
opponent was given a voucher PO you know
sweet Soares in Moscow espanol
sativas avianna Republic the presumably
difficult Arabic the piece of Pradaxa
may do you see a common factor PACU
Hamas Nathan LUMO only fluency parle
avec is a super oklahoma sampling
Nouveau Donilon who own a Persian a lay
native kita goodness imagination
yes your default receptive MMO may super
deform
don knapp of the cal this shows your map
of the carriage a prism MC for the
pitiful voila
Cisco Julie dinner singer sir su j and
there you have it
speaking like a native bye for now
[Music]